sure there are some arithmetic operators
used for performing calculations in a s
when you use more than one arithmetic
operator in an expression operations of
priority one are performed before
operations of priority 2 and so on
consecutive operations that have the
same priority are performed from right
to left with in priority one from left
to right within priorities 2 and 3 in
the next screen we will have a look at
logical operators used in SAS
sure here are some logical operators
used to compare to SAS values the result
of logical comparison in SAS is in a
true or false format in the next few
screens we will observe how to use
logical SAS expressions with conditional
statements to control the flow of
program execution of any program can be
controlled using conditional statements
upon execution of these statements the
prog compiler decides the set of
statements to be executed and the set to
be ignored SAS offers different
conditional statements to select the set
of observations to be processed in
program execution the first one in this
series is the where statement this
statement can be used to select
observations during the PR OC step and
data step the syntax for using the where
statement is as shown here the where
expression specifies a condition for
selecting observations it can be any
valid SAS expression the where statement
works for both character and numeric
variables to specify a condition based
on the value of a character variable
enclose the value in quotation marks
considering that the comparison will be
case sensitive in the next screen we
will show an example to understand how
the where statement works in a full one
only those observations from dataset
clinic dot admit with an age greater
than 30 will be processed in the next
example we combine two comparisons using
the or operator here only those
observations from dataset clinic dot
admit which have act level either low or
mod will be processed next we will
discuss the if-then-else condition
operator the f
then statement executes an SAS statement
when the condition in the if Clause is
true any comparison and logical
operators can be used in the if
conditional expression any numeric value
other than zero or missing is true and a
value of zero or missing is false the
syntax for using this is as shown if the
condition in the if Clause is evaluated
to be true then statement set one is
executed if the condition in the if
Clause is evaluated to be false and
condition in the if Clause is evaluated
to be true then statement set to will be
executed in case the expressions in if
and else if are evaluated to false then
only statement set 3 will be executed in
the next screen we will take an example
to understand the flow of the if then
else statement